to work in this field I will talk about
learner outcomes from this program and
we'll go through the enrollment video
what to do
um and or the end we'll take your
questions so please put those into the Q
a function
of Zoom or if you're watching on a
streaming service put those into the
comment or chat functions and we will
get to those in the Q a at the end of
the presentation
over to you Mike
great thanks Jordan
um hi everybody I'm Mike Ash uh a little
bit older than my my picture uh I'm the
director for the center of technology
management education we're part of the
California Institute of Technology that
engages industry and then government
with uh learning programs uh these
include public programs and boot camps
like what we're going to talk about
today uh there are also uh several
others that are really designed for
technology driven organizations
I've been here
in Caltech for about five years working
in high tech for 25 as a project manager
and an analyst
and spending a lot of time in
foreign
that's what they can point to
say they've done this type of work
some people have a scheduled difficulty
I think the numbers stop changing so I'm
going to share with you the results
hmm
about 40 of the audience said either
not finding a comprehensive curriculum
or not getting the practical
experience and exposure that they they
need to be able to demonstrate the
skills so
yeah yeah turn it back over to you yeah
um interesting so and it
it's it supports part of our hypothesis
that uh while there are short programs
out there and uh easily available
um learning programs from all kinds of
sources and we encourage you to to use
those when they're from good trusted
sources
what we wanted to do is put together
something that
can help somebody part-time
get a comprehensive enough background to
really move the needle
um on their career
we teamed up with simply learn about
three years ago to develop uh six or
seven uh different boot camp programs
with Caltech and we helped design this
with them there's a QR code there that
would just take you to the home page for
the the different boot camps but what
this the data analytics bootcamp is is
comprehensive and intensive uh learning
experience that goes on for about six
months
um it is part-time so people who are
fully employed can take it uh there are
some pre-recorded uh videos and sessions
that you can do during the week but
really the aim is just to get to the
weekend and it's on Saturdays and
Sundays and spend about eight hours
uh with instructors and with a class a
cohort of about 30 people and really
dive into
using data using tools we'll talk about
the tools in just a minute
um but really getting Hands-On so how do
we use this how do we create charts how
do we create insights out of all this
uh it is uh modern it aligns with
industry you're using the right tools uh
but this is really something that is is
comprehensive
uh and what we focus on is project-based
learning so through the The Experience
we're going to be working on
uh several mini projects to focus your
work so it's applied and your in your
new skills and then culminates in a
Capstone project at the end and we'll
talk about that in just a minute
um like I said there's uh this is a
certificate academic certificate program
uh you get continuing education credits
uh which is very helpful when your
employer is reimbursing your tuition
uh so that's something we most people
take our programs uh have that or
they're investing in themselves
to change careers or change
employers what uh through the
certificate program not only do you get
the certificate that looks similar to
this from from us you'll experience uh
convocation or welcoming that we do uh
every every quarter where we celebrate
our graduates uh you have access to a
private LinkedIn network uh where we'll
share other uh programs from Caltech uh
news and events that that you can join
and then one of the things that also
really sets this apart from other
programs is the ability to have a six at
the end six more months of career
assistance and uh Stuart we'll talk
about that but uh this is really
powerful it's not job placement it's
really preparing you for uh presenting
yourself so your resume LinkedIn also
um on GitHub where you're keeping your
projects where you're keeping your code
and your work
um your published work
I imagine uh people on the phone know
who uh on zoom and and uh LinkedIn uh
Caltech this is the California Institute
of Technology we are a private
university in Pasadena California
uh been around for a while uh we've got
a few
um
a few smart people around uh that really
get into data science and data
engineering and analytics and we're
trying to draw on them to make this a
better program
uh what does it take to be a part of
this uh you we're really looking for
adult Learners this is like a
postgraduate program
um you need to have some understanding
of of programming and and math but uh
if you have an analytical mindset I
think you'll probably fit well because
we're going to teach you a lot of those
those Basics
um
we do encourage people who have uh some
amount of work experience into this so
they really have context so when is
financial data what is operational data
things like that
um but let's just do another poll about
you
um
polls open
um so again folks on socials can use A B
C or D
um are you currently studying do you
have a little bit of experience three to
five years or more than five years
and we'll give you another 10 seconds
please get your answers in
and
we'll close the poll
now
and you can see that we have a audience
uh
about 20 percent Uh current students but
the rest of you have
work experience many of you more than
five years
excellent
um
so this program will the boot camp will
get into what the the tools are in the
curriculum just a second uh
should should fit pretty well and so
let's talk about how it's kind of right
um
Unfortunately today we don't have a live
tour of the learning environment
um we had to make a scheduled change but
uh Stuart can you talk a little bit
about
the the learning environment and then
I'll pick up on the next step absolutely
yes
um so the the program was delivered
entirely online through a single
learning management system simply
learned developed uh which is the reason
why Caltech chose to partner with us
the uh
really believe that the learning
environment
gives their Learners a really good
platform on which to learn you get to
manage your curriculum from the home
page of the learning management system
you see all of the component courses
that make up the boot camp you get track
your progress through each of the
courses
um
generally speaking you can't move to the
next course until you finish the one
you're on so it tracks and prompts you
to stay on schedule stay on target and
guide you through the sequence of
programs uh as Mike mentioned every
weekend you have the live virtual
classroom environment where you interact
with your instructor directly
you can follow their lecture you can ask
their questions and get them answered
live you can interact with your peers
with
class
in the middle of the week you have
access to review materials study
materials
programming code that your instructor
has shared with you for your projects
you do your
lab work and your tests on the same
learning environment and
once you get to the end of the program
the last module is a final project
which you do Under the mentorship of
your
instructor you'll hear a little bit more
about that in
the presentation but that's a three to
four week process where you meet with
your instructor weekly to review your
progress and you solve a problem that
you've chosen from the available
industry-based real world problems
and your solution becomes part as Mike
mentioned part of your GitHub portfolio
something that you can show to your
employer or potential future employers
and demonstrate how you've done this
work
um along the way as you complete each
module the learning management system
lets you unlock the certificate that
shows you've completed the module and
once you've completed your Capstone it
allows you to unlock the final
certificate from
Caltech and along the way you have
support tools you have a learner
community that you can pose questions to
your peers you can contact your
instructors
you can get 24x7 support
or both the platform itself as well as
the subject matter so all of that is
available to you on your desktop your
laptop a lot of it on the on your mobile
device
or wherever and whenever you want to do
your work and do your studies
that is the learning environment
great uh thanks Kurt uh one thing I want
to emphasize there is that uh Caltech
and simply learn are heavily invested in
Student Success outcomes
and you get you know you have 24 7
support in being able to use the
platform and then also the availability
of the instructors uh to to guide you so
uh we want to make sure that you're
you're learning you're getting over any
obstacles and uh and and progressing
through the the boot camp so uh that is
it's really important for us that
that you get the most out of the
experience
the way that the six months breaks down
is like we've said it's most of the work
is on the the weekends or about
um uh four hours
uh each day on Saturday and Sunday so
that is a commitment personal commitment
and and work commitment uh what we're
going to do early on start off with
um kind of induction and orientation
sessions if there's
uh if you need Refreshers on
on certain things you can take those
early on
we'll get into Excel how Excel is used
and this is really kind of you know how
do you get around without a spreadsheet
what is a spreadsheet uh hopefully you
already know that coming in
um but all the different uh key formulas
that you would use and statistics and
Analysis and being able to manage data
move data manipulate data clean the data
uh present data we'll get through uh
leading practices
um how to get through all the learning
all the different shortcuts
uh so you're really quick about it
um and especially how are you going to
be using charts
um charts will cover everything from
kind of micro charts like sparklines
through
um
waterfall charts scattered plot
bar graphs line graphs histograms
everything
uh then what we're going to do is really
take a deep dive into SQL structural
query language and learn how to write uh
queries that are going to hit a live
databases or other
um
data repositories other spreadsheets and
how can you take
information data from different sources
bring those together and build what
you're you're trying to build whether
it's synthesized data or also the
visualizations
uh we'll cover a bit of python in that
and being able to create workbooks uh
for doing some of the analytics uh we'll
get into Tableau if you haven't used
Tableau before
um you should really check it out uh I
started using Tableau in 2007 early
adopter
did use it quite a bit in in my
Consulting I came from IBM and Deloitte
and press Waterhouse
uh using that not only just speeds up
analysis but being able to really see
um new insights
um
so we'll we'll take you all the way
through all the different tools uh using
it as a desktop tools server tools
um creating dashboards and other things
we will also spend time using AWS being
able to
manage and set up different cloud-based
uh repositories
and then a Stuart described the Capstone
project which is where you take all of
these skills
and a plan to a particular project that
will demonstrate everything that you've
learned
um I think we've just kind of covered uh
all these tools
um
and let's see
Capstone
[Music]
we've we've covered if you have
questions about this we'll cover it in
uh in the Q a yeah one thing I would
like to mention about the Capstone is
the uh the fact that you have the choice
of several different
projects several different problems that
are posed as what a company in the real
world has to solve
data analytics challenge they have to
meet
and then you get to pick the one that
interests you the most so that you have
the choice to work on that
I mentioned you work on that for about
three to four weeks meeting with your
instructor weekly so that you can avoid
any dead ends or rabbit holes and
get to the end successfully and that
becomes your
almost your final exam of the entire
program
that's what the Capstone project does
for you and you get to take that with
you and show that off to
anybody in the future that you want to
demonstrate your skills to
uh and we had we just spoken about this
briefly earlier I'm sorry that I had a
duplicate slide in here for you but um
but just to review you manage your
curriculum all the stages that that Mike
mentioned
do everything on the
platform itself you don't need to switch
between platforms or by other
equipment or software to do this
and everything
supported 24 7
by simply learning caltex
so in Caltech ctme our Rick Hefner who's
actually now our executive director
and I've worked with similar and to
develop the curriculum of the program in
fact we'll take a step back
simply learned how to acquire also full
stack Academy last year this program is
was part of that and carries a lot of
the the great content that was in it we
also worked with the team there
and uh one of the things I didn't
mention as a part of the instruction is
we have Caltech ctme instructors uh that
will be delivering a monthly Master
Class sessions so this is on top of of
the the boot camp there's no extra cost
or enrollment fees it's all a part of
the program so you'll be learning from
an industry expert that's Affiliated and
and working here
and start I'm going to turn it over to
you for industry outcomes
sure
um thank you Mike the
profiles of people who enrolled in this
program you're going to be working
alongside students Learners from lots of
different companies and industries
again Caltech ctme offers
education programs for people working in
Industry so
your peers in the in the classes are
likely to come from these companies as
they have in the past and from many
different Industries um
this is not
just a
course for people who work in
information technology
this is a
skill area that is vital to every
company uh in every industry so we
track people from Pharma from retail
from manufacturing
telecommunications Banking and Financial
um so you'll get a lot of cross-exposure
different sectors
and Mike mentioned very briefly
that um
there's a career assistance
portion to this program so if you want
to move to the next slide right
the career assist service is
something that extends for six months
after you get your certificate and
it is not a job guarantee program but it
is a job search assistance program that
helps you prepare for and
conduct your job search and allows you
gives you resources to
direct your career yeah
take care of your career Direction in
the future so one of the components main
components is through our partner Talent
Inc
this is available to users or Learners
in the U.S so I know that we had
somebody inquiring from Brazil and while
you can take the program unfortunately
we don't give the
Talent Inc part of this to users outside
of the
USA but for those of you who are in the
US you have access to the exclusive job
portal that Talent Inc runs yeah which
is valuable it gives you access to
certain exclusive job listings
um I think that the more valuable parts
of the program are the resume review and
rewrite and the interview prep service
because
today if you apply for a job that resume
goes through an automated tracking
system with an AI bot that
evaluates your resume against the job
description so your resume first has to
be in a format yeah that the
AI bot can recognize and can readily
match to a job description and
pass you through that first filter
and then once that
you make it through that filter your
resume still has to go in front of a
human being it has to be attractive and
eye-catching for that purpose so being
able to balance those two functions of
your resume is almost an art form and
that's one of the great things about
having the resume review and rewrite
service the other part the interview
prep service
similarly you're going to have to go
through many rounds of interviews once
your resume
attracts the attention of a recruiter or
hiring manager and so you need to be
prepared not only for the technical
questions about data analytics that
you'll be asked but also for
the cultural questions the management
fit questions the team player questions
that give your hiring manager the
comfort that you'll be a contributor to
their organization
um being able to sit down one-on-one uh
Zoom sessions with
interview prep
doing mock interviews of different types
that's really a valuable way to make
sure you put your best foot forward when
you interview
moving on
oh yeah sorry
of course
usually it's me that's uh
so I got to keep up with the
here we go so assembly runs a series of
webinars that are available to the
public and you'll be able to access
sessions
that talk about your career care and
feeding
advice for your career how to do it job
search effectively and use the tools
that are out there
you'll be able to review the state of
the industry and what trends are coming
up
for opportunities and data analytics
field and you'll also be able to take
short courses one hour
mini lessons all of these are free these
are available to you lifelong so this is
part of our support to you for your
career on an ongoing basis
and then um
just want to ask the question
are you interested based on what you've
heard
so far
from Mike and myself are you interested
in enrolling in the program so I'll
leave this open for just about 20
seconds because it's a yes or no
question
and this is
this is not a commitment
um
to sign up this is uh your interest in
signing up
I think the numbers have stopped
changing so I will share with you the
poll result
almost 90 percent of our respondents
said that they are interested
in enrolling in this program which is
great
and um
to learn you know what
what more information might you need to
make a decision or if you find that the
program is too entry level for you or
or something different uh throw that in
the in the Q a
exactly
so the enrollment steps are very
straightforward
um
simply learn administers this part of
the process so you email us at ask us at
simplylearn.net
and I'm going to throw that
transformation into the chat so that
it's at your fingertips
um we will contact you one of our
learning Consultants will contact you
and verify
your eligibility criteria which are
pretty straightforward for this program
um
and
much of that will involve your level of
interest and your commitment
to putting in the time and effort into
the program because
one of the things we want to be sure is
as Mike said is that we're supporting
your success so we want to make sure
that you're
interested and committed to it so that
you don't set
but unrealistic expectations and then
besides that it's not for you after
you've enrolled so we do that beforehand
and we send you an admission offer
once we've done that
I had the next
the next cohort is starting in about a
week
with an induction session that gives you
an orientation to the funding management
system and the curriculum and gets you
set up
we'll give access to the learning
management system and get you prepared
the first classes start February 27th
um and again the extend for about six
months after that
the price of this program is ten
thousand dollars
um do not have to pay the ten thousand
dollars in the lump sum up front because
we will finance it on a monthly basis uh
about 12 monthly payments
um
zero cost financing
and um as Mike has often reminded our
audiences uh your employer may offer
tuition reimbursement if you work for a
company that has that benefit
by all means find out from your Learning
and Development Department uh if that's
one of your
perks for your company because that can
cover some are all the cost of programs
of this type so
um
again it's not something that's offered
by Caltech or simply learn but it is
something that many employers do offer
to employees
so again financing yeah and that the
reimbursement the financing is from
Simply learned so
you do have access to that
um as an option and then
um whether or not your employer
reimburses their policy but um the email
address and the link to the program page
are in your chat and
please do reach out to us could ask us
simplylearn.net
find out more and to get started
so we want to ask one more question
before we get to q a
and
for those of you who are interested in
enrolling how soon
would you plan to enroll or is it
something you want to join the
cohort starting this month
uh are you looking
maybe for the one after that
looking further down the road one of the
things we always say is that if this if
it's something that is going to change
your life in your career for the better
um it's generally
a good idea to start sooner than later
um that's a question that helps us plan
the the Cadence of of how how many times
this is offered through the year
um because we do try to keep the cohorts
around 30 people
um
but uh understanding this is
it helps us a bit
and I'll close the poll because numbers
have stopped changing so here's the
result
so um
yeah almost uh more than 50 almost 60
percent of the audience wants to study
either this month or within the next
couple of months so that's great again
if you are looking further down the road
please do contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net right away and we will
answer any questions you have and we'll
keep you in touch so that you know what
the future
cohort's uh timings are
not move to questions and answers
I do not know why my camera does this I
know that I'm completely washed out but
uh yeah I was gonna say that I'm going
to turn off the video so that you don't
get distracted by this ghost yeah you're
not the sign again
it's a
a weird Quirk of this particular video
camera I have
um I apologize for that but let me um
we have a couple of questions
um
the engine asks uh as a beginner in the
data field can you use the projects that
you do in the program uh in your resume
and your portfolio and show those off to
um potential employers
Mike if you want to comment on on how
students would use that
um I'm I'm sorry the phone was ringing
here
yeah the uh
audience member renjini uh says as a
beginner in the data field
um can we use the projects we do as part
of the course in our resume our
portfolio to show off or work
absolutely yes
um because and
you know being able to use analytics and
and
um you know you've got the charts you've
got what what are how are you
interpreting what does that information
is telling you
um it's a it's a visual story right
um and you need to be able to to use
that uh of course you're not putting
charts in your resume but you're
providing uh through uh your your letter
or if they're asking for
um
code if you have a website
um be able to make those things
accessible and do that through multiple
methods to be able to give them access
to that and also when you're in
screening interviews let them know that
you have that to be able to to show
because that can really set you apart
um we have a tech question from user my
tech refs
who ask which database environment is
used in this course is it Oracle SQL
server what type of environment they're
going to talk about
um connecting the multiple
multiple systems
um and when you're in you know
that SQL is you know you know standard
but when we're getting into how AWS
connects to those or Tableau tablet
connects to pretty much everything
um so it's
it's uh
it varies
and and that brings up a question from
Gabriel who asks if the coursework
covers API development
um for that that data connection and
extraction
oops you there oh I'm sorry yeah uh
Gabriel asks if the course covers API
development
or do we use it it didn't in the past
um
I would
it seems like there will be some of that
um but that I actually need to
get that answered myself okay
um and then well let me just say this
there are a couple ways of of doing that
the other is integration that's
um
doing Simple connections like you're
pointing at another platform and here's
its identity and the and the and it's
secret and rest and soap interfaces
web hooks
um I don't know how much they get into
web hooks uh part of that is covered but
I I do need to get back and give you a
better answer
some of it's really low code and easy
interfaces
right
um more of the emphasis is on the use of
apis rather than the development of them
but
um we have
uh renjini asks a question which I'll
answer which is how long do you have
access to the study materials
and you you can access the
class recordings and other specific
materials of the of the program for six
months after the uh you earn your
certificate
some of the materials are part of the
simply learned portfolio that you are
able to access
on an ongoing basis definitely
but some of them some of the access does
expire after six months so
um
I do not have any experience in the it
field will this course work for me what
would you say Mike I'd say yes because
most business analysts don't work in I.T
um they're they're a part of the
business
um or they're they're a part of uh
Finance or they're embedded within the
finance and embedded in the business or
and almost every function has analysts
um and being able to use
Tableau
um and maybe some SQL but it everybody
that on my teams yeah they weren't I.T
people they were all either mbas or
um other analysts
and you're using the tools and you're
you're creating charts for business and
of course you're also going to be in
doing that through Excel and PowerPoint
so yeah
um
Dolly you mentioned your teams and and
work you've done in the past
golly I asked when Caltech is hiring
um for its own staff for creating
analytics and similar things do they
look for this type of certificate
for a data analytics certificate yeah if
you're if you were going to hire
somebody for your depend depending on
the role that's that's open uh
uh Finance team uh operations teams
HR uh Grant Management yes those aren't
they're not looking for phds who know
data science
um if you are looking for a job with a
with a PhD lab or PhD and his his or her
lab and the grad students that may be
something totally different but this is
aimed at business Analytics
um
Ellen is already enrolled in the Caltech
data science boot camp congratulations
yes um he's asking how this program is
different and does he have access to the
same Career Services if I can answer the
latter part
um yes I believe you have access to the
same Career Services through Talent Inc
and should contact
the
learning consultant that you're working
with the learner success manager that
you're working with to ask about those
Services
um
Mike can you address how the curriculum
is a bit different between the two
yeah so Ellen's talking about the data
science program that's much more machine
learning Centric so you're spending more
time and
uh Python and different libraries uh num
num5 for math sci-fi for for science
um
creating uh Jupiter workbooks uh
training ml or training AI algorithms uh
as opposed to
we're going to be in Excel we're going
to be creating charts Based on data if
we're going to be manipulating some data
and
using visualization tools
um and so one is really
the data analytics program like I
mentioned before much more for business
Analytics
data science a little bit more broad but
because getting into you're getting into
more of the machine learning aspects
which can cross over to it roles or
um
uh again help either helping in Labs or
helping with staff research and so on
we had a couple of questions about
grants or scholarships for the program
uh which we do not offer but we do offer
the financing option
so that you can
pay it over time rather than in a single
lump sum so
hope that answers that question
um
adelaja mentions that have a Masters in
data management and analytics but are
presently competent just in Excel
um
what
are their chances in finding jobs with
that skill set and would this help
so
this will expand on on your your base in
Excel
would SQL if if you're not already
familiar with that
uh you'll spend quite a bit of time uh
learning that and
uh setting up tableau
doing it in Cloud environments while
we're while we're on AWS
that that is that might be also
different but
yeah that's how those are are helpful at
it getting into more maybe
can still be entry level but prepping
you for um
more robust opportunities
with employers
and more props a bit more of a practical
orientation than the master's program
completed
um
and I'm trying to interpret the question
from Madonna and I'm sorry if I don't
understand it correctly but
um Dom was asking if you can comment on
um
how
Innovation this is more of a
philosophical question how does an
innovation uh help guide technological
advancement
um in this kind of environment to to
help people achieve their goals and
objectives
I don't know if there's a say that again
I don't have it in front of me yeah I'm
looking at it it says uh
how do how can Innovation deliver
um
technological advancement in ways to
deal with technological changes
so that you can be successful in your
career
being able to understand the pace of of
Technology
um
and how it affects business and changes
to
its financial position its competitive
position
understanding the arena that it operates
in the context of the business the
employees
all of that can be used to either
support enable push innovation
incremental Innovation but
it's starting to get toward breakthrough
Innovations
um
thank you
um and final question
um BMS asks
uh if they're currently using Tableau
and SQL in their work um
use this course
um going to be helpful to them
or it depends on are you
um
a heavy user of Tableau
um or in cloud-based environments
multiple dashboards knowing Tableau
server
it it depends you know it
if you're already like that this may not
be the best program for you
um and maybe the data science program is
but
they're all different you know it's been
probably as a
when I mentioned I started using Tableau
and doing a lot of Analytics
I didn't need to
hook up to a lot of other databases I'm
working on discrete data sets from
clients
and
I didn't need to be that much of a of a
power user then
um things change
um
and I think if you're already a power
user and doing a lot of these things
um yeah then it may not be a fit for you
and and the whole
objective of Caltech ctmus programs is
to meet use you know Learners where they
are so if you're at that level in your
career you may want to look at other
programs that will take you further
um if you're not at that level yet then
this may be the program for you now
there is also the
um so if you think about it as a as a
progression so data analytics program if
we have the data science bootcamp which
is very similar good and structure to
this but like I said it's
uh the content's a bit different but
it's the same kind of six months
intensive program then there is the
machine learning and Ai and that is much
more of a deep dive into
um deep learning deep down deep learning
no pun intended
um and uh training algorithms and
putting those in place so that's a
little bit more of uh we're trying to
prepare you to be an expert in that I
would say that's probably more advanced
uh that would be maybe a great one for
someone to go into but they're also
using
uh machine learning in either business
or engineering environments development
environments operations
and even research
that covers all the questions we've
received so far so okay you can move on
foreign
the final poll question
uh this is for anybody who's expressed
interest today do you need assistance
from us to um
move ahead if you have all the
information you need please let us know
and if you're still looking to get
questions answered and or if you want to
contact us
get the process started please let us
know
some of you are confident that the
you're ready to go so
again this allows us to gauge some
interest
and what resources we need to put
forward
we'll close the poll in five seconds
and
25 percent of you said that you need
assistance contact us please ask us at
simplyline.net the rest of you
um just go ahead and
get started
and we look forward to welcoming you
into the Caltech learning community
and simply learn
family
um I want to thank Mike for being here
today and taking us through this program
thank you everybody for your time
I want to thank everybody who's here uh
on Zoom or our streaming services
or spending the time today with us
and again contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net or use the QR code to
get to the
home page for the data analytics
bootcamp
and that concludes our webinar for today
so
hey everybody thank you and we hope to
see you in class